when we first met oh you were young and
wild oh yeah we were i think we i think
it was at a bar it was a restaurant yes
shay jay's jj's in santa monica
with luke wilson with a wilson
and you were doing alex and emma
together i think is that oh that's what
it was uh-huh and i was dating him but
you were i think he was also dating
other people
it was an open relationship we were
young it's i've been there with a wilson
too
it's so fun because when you're young
you're like it's low stakes
you know we're just young we're having
fun we're all playing acting hanging out
you know you're not taking it all so
seriously and it was fun and we had the
best time we had the best time but i
remember sitting on just because you i
mean you've been in the in the spotlight
for so your whole life
and as a little girl looking at
actresses
drew is one of them where you're like
you know i mean for any young girl my
age it was like true
and so i remember sitting
and like
i used to get people saying like oh you
kind of look like drew barrymore oh what
a compliment to me i'll take that one
yeah which is why i ended up doing you
on snl as well oh my god can you do drew
barrymore i was like i don't think so oh
my god you're so so little oh i'm such a
baby
oh you weren't oh
so you nailed it by the way it's magical
it's your it's your mouth
that's what i realized is that when your
mouth moves also you have so much
expression in your face you know and so
i was like if i just like commit to the
expression
and you do that thing or you get really
excited like you know so funny i was
doing the movie fever pitch with jimmy
fallon and the fairly brothers were
directing it and they were like say they
loved us to surprise each other and
improv and get unique reactions so
obviously they had hubbubbed on the side
and kibbutz and jimmy came back and he
was like you know i love how crooked
your mouth is the side of your face and
he made sort of an and you know probably
i'm sure what's an inappropriate joke
it's a fairly
um and i
had never
realized and that was the moment that
changed my life and held up a mirror to
the fact that you that you have a little
you know what i never noticed it before
jimmy fallon said it
on the set a favorite pic
and now i i i see it well it's kind of
like you know my mom is the same thing
you know when she smiles she has her
like big beautiful crooked smile and i
think it's just like
i think it's just
the most amazing quirk
[Music]